my name is John Smithson right I'm here
from the Korea Global Agenda Council we
are discussions of focused primarily on
the perennial challenge of the DPRK and
in particular the nuclear challenge
posed by the DPRK to regional security
looking ahead to the future and the
establishment of a peaceful prosperous
and stable East Asia our deliberations
have focused on a series of initiatives
designed to deal with both the nuclear
threat the assistance of economic
problems in the DPRK issues to do with
misperception and misrepresentation of
North Korea as well as questions of
fostering closer engagement in a wide
area of cultural initiatives our
provisions are mixture of both concrete
new proposals involving broadening the
framework of international relations
beyond the old Cold War aligned
structures as well as consideration of
the specific role South Korea can play
promote inclusive dialogue with
deviation